[Music]
[Applause]
so thank you for instance from the nice
introduction and thank you for staying
around here on Sunday afternoon and so
my name is Julie interpreter and I'm
currently working as a data scientist to
go data-driven but as my previous job I
worked as a PhD student at the naval
Netherlands Cancer Institute or the nki
and I essentially my research focused on
researching breast cancer and with
genomics data and so one thing I noticed
when I was talking with my new
colleagues is that if you talk about
machine learning in the medical field
that people very quickly jump to images
which they can easily relate to but for
a genomics data this is much more
abstract because people aren't used to
thinking about these kind of things and
that's why I thought it would be nice to
maybe it's a meeting like this to
introduce some of the concepts here and
give you an idea of what it's all about
so that's why we're here today and I'm
giving this talk together with Nanna
who's a former colleague of mine also
from the nevians Cancer Institute and
this talk will essentially consists of
two parts where I'll first try to give
some Bell biological background and some
introduction into the world of tumor
sequencing and what kind of dates you
get from this and then Anna will take
over in the second part on explaining
how you take data from these sequencing
approaches and use them to create
machine learning models for example in
this case focusing on predicting drug
responses which is one of the main
topics in his of his thesis so first I
want to start very broad so with some
biology and as many of you might really
know from from some biology course in
your secondary school our body
essentially consists of I think around
40 trillion of these very small things
called cells and each of these cells is
governed by a strand a long strand
inside the nucleus of these cells called
DNA which if she assumed in on this it
essentially is a long double helix
strand of which which contains many
functional elements called genes and
what these genes do they essentially
encode for the building blocks of the
cell called proteins and what happens
inside the cell is that first these
things are read off by some settling
machinery in a process called
transcription to create a messenger
molecule could RNA
and this is then later moves to
somewhere else in the cell and then
translated in a process called
translation into proteins and proteins
are essentially one of the most
important biological building blocks of
the cell because these actually do
things in the cell and this is a quite
tightly regulated process which always
ensure that for a given gene you always
have the right amount of protein that
you have in the cell for performing a
particular function and what's important
to realize is that these proteins don't
act in unison but they act in quite
complicated networks and I just wanted
to give one example of a signaling
network which is often used of often
shown and in this case you can for
example imagine sorry that there's a
protein which acts as a receptor on the
outside of the cell listening for some
kind of signal and when it encounters a
signal in this case indicated by this
block EGF here it realizes signal inside
the cell to another protein and then
again to another and this kind of
signals cascade at some point and relays
to the inside of the cell
some kind of signal indicating that you
keep on surviving keep on growing etc
and well this is quite easy to
understand because it's just a linear
cascade you also have other interactions
where you for example of other proteins
which then acts as a break on this kind
on the proteins in this pathway so
blocking the growth signal and you also
have more complicated things where you
have signaling pathways in parallel in
the cell which then also sometimes
interact with each other and basically
resulting in quite complex networks
which are quite complex behavior and
this is just a very simple example
because if you plot all the network of
all these proteins and their
interactions it quickly looks something
more like this where you can see that
there's a lot going on it's much more
difficult to understand what's actually
happening in a network like this so then
very briefly what is cancer so if
everything is going alright in our body
cells work together to create these
complex structures in this case like
kind of a skin structure where they form
nice roads and then basically well do
what they should do to create a property
structure and what sometimes happens
during the course of our life between
the course of life is cell is that they
accumulate mutations either because
we've been sitting out in the Sun too
long or I've been smoking or stuff like
that and these mutations essentially
then if we don't project that back on
the network like this we can imagine
that a mutation in this case might for
example knock out these proteins so make
it non-functional and as a result this
the signaling pathway that showed is no
longer controlled or repressed by this
protein which make this much more active
than it should be and this case
signaling that the cell just you just
keep on growing keep on growing keep on
growing and what then happens in this
case what can happen is that this cell
the mutation can keep on dividing and
create this kind of mass that then
displaces normal cells and ruins the
tissue structure locally and if this
continues further into tumorigenic
process you get this behavior where the
tumor cells start invading into the
surrounding tissues and if you're
unlucky they also start segregating off
and migrating to other parts of the body
which is a process known as metastasis
and of course if we look at the clinic
one of the important questions in cancer
research is if a patient comes into the
clinic and they already have cancer what
is the best approach forward so what's
the best way to treat this patient to
ensure that they recover from this and
so traditionally one of the more use
protease for this is to being to give
the good patients chemotherapy or in the
case of breast cancer or prostate cancer
you're stressed from hormonal therapies
and if you're lucky these therapies can
have a very good effect and eradicate
the tumor which is the best case would
you see very often is that tumors also
sometimes I do regress or give sometimes
tables the disease so this essentially
prolongs the life of a patient but
doesn't really cure them and if you're
very unlucky
what about what happens a lot of the
times that you MERS just keep on growing
and the patient dies eventually and one
of the surprising things about this is
if if you look at this patients often
convenor with quite similar tumors but
some patients respond very well to
chemotherapy or to some kind of therapy
whilst other patients don't respond at
all and therefore one of the really key
questions here is can we identify why
some patients respond to treatment while
others don't and can we use this
information to maybe devise new
treatments or assigned people that
patients for the right treatment groups
and this essentially
one of the main ideas behind the
approach called personalized medicine
where the idea was to when a patient
comes into the clinic to take a biopsy
from the tomb of the patient and then
feed this into a big machine called a
sequencing machine and well this machine
essentially does it allows us to measure
some kind of some features on the genome
or the genetic side of these tumors such
as mutations how strongly genes are
expressed and how how often they're
contained in the genome and then the
idea behind this is that we can use
these features to predict if they will
respond for example to specific drugs
based on the mutations they have maybe
also identify some tumor specific
vulnerabilities which we can use to
devise new treatments and so just to
give a brief introduction to our tumor
sequencing works the idea is that we use
some kind of lab process to extract the
DNA from the cell and feed it into the
sequencing machine and what the
sequencing machine essentially does it
improves generates many many short
sequence reads which are about 50 to 300
base pairs long
so each base player in this case
indicated by an AAC a G or a T and so
like I said each sequences around 300
long and then to make sense of where
these reads came from so from which
genes of the genome we typically align
these back to a known reference genome
which was generated I think now ten
years ago and just to give some idea of
the scale this genome is around 3.2
billion base pairs long so these are
really short sequencing reads and once
we do this with some kind of with the
text alignment algorithm generally it
looks something like this where we take
the sequence we read some Apple onto the
genome and then once we have these
mapped reads we can then look at the
positions at each genetic position along
the genome and then compare the
sequences that we see in this tumor or
in this tumor sample to the reference
that we know and in this case you would
see that the the letters in each
position is the same except for here we
see a C instead of a G and this might
indicate that this is a mutation is in
this tumor which might have an important
biological impact somewhere on the cell
another level we can also use the RNA
which I mentioned briefly earlier and
stick that in the sequencer which also
gives us a lot of sequin
reads and we can also line these to the
reference genome and in this case
because this measures this is basically
the how high cells expressed we can then
align these to the genes in the genome
and then count how many sequence reads
we have at a specific gene in the cell
and this gives us some kind of idea of
how strongly a cell gene is activated in
that in these cells so this case because
we have a lot of sequence reads mapping
to this first gene here it would have a
high expression level whilst because we
only have a few reads here which would
have low expression for gene B so this
is a bit basically the basics behind
tumor sequencing and some challenges in
analyzing this kind of data is that it's
quite a complicated multi-process a
multi-step process where we do a lot of
different steps like contaminant
filtering the alignment I mentioned but
also a lot of quality control mutate and
also downstream things like the mutation
calling and beside that there are a lot
of different tools involved they often
written in different languages because
it's all academic software and they have
a lot of complex dependencies which
makes them difficult to install as well
and what's also very fun is that they
have a lot of tools doing the same
things but they often give very
different results which has led to some
cases for example where people have
advocated for mutation calling to just
run five or six different algorithms and
take some kind of weird intersection of
the results and this makes it difficult
to kind of to kind of formulate this
process cleanly and also maybe on the
logistical side of things this also this
process also have used many large files
which are typically 10 to hundreds
gigabytes per sample which in a hospital
environment can be quite challenging to
store efficiently so given this
complexity at least in my job I thought
it was very important to try and
facilitate the reproducible analysis of
this kind of genomics approaches and to
do so for my own work I use two basic
tools one is bio Condor which is for
those who've you know anaconda is
essentially a repository and anaconda
repository but then for biometrics tools
and they also have a lot of
bioinformatics related Python are
packages which makes it very easy to
properly define your software
environments to make them reproducible
elsewhere and beside that also used to a
called snake Meg which are going through
in the following slides which I
essentially uses a workflow management
tool for defining the different tasks
and creating analysis tags so just to
give you idea what the Segway looks like
it's essentially a DSL which generates
Python code in the end and this is just
what a simple rule looks like where a
rule has a name in this case a line it
takes an input which is a certain file
it generates an output which is also a
file name in this case you can add
certain extra parameters which don't
have to be have to be files but in this
case this is also our path and in this
and it can also then use these inputs
outputs to generate in this case a shell
command where I call to call bwa with
this index with this input and then
generate a certain output and of course
it's useful if you're just regenerating
one file
but smack-bang also allows you to expect
to put wildcards into your inputs and
outputs as many as you want which allows
you to generalize this rule in this case
if I want to then generate a sample with
a certain sample it knows that it has to
interpolate this name into the input to
find out which input for holid needs and
beside besides running certain shell
commands you can also it also has good
integration for Python or for our
scripts and you can also run arbitrary
Python code in here if you want to and
some advanced features that also like
which I just wanted to briefly mention
is that you can also define remote files
in this case I'll show an example for s3
where it can as an input file you can
specify this specify file first three to
use and it will automatically check if
this is updated and download it if
needed you can tell snake make that some
files temporary in which case it will
just throw them in ways as long as as
soon as they're no longer needed which
is nice for these big file sizes you can
define the resource that certain rule
needs in terms of threads but also a
memory or anything you really want and
you can also per rule you can define a
certain environment to use if you have a
specific software version that you need
to use and this can be a common
environment but there's also support for
docker singularity if you want to go
through the container route and what
essentially it looks like if you put
this all in a big snake make file you
start with the kind of default wall with
tell snake maker which files you want to
generate in this case I'm asking for two
files to some files they
looks for rules to generate these files
if they're not present in the file
system in this case it finds that this
align rule can generate these files and
it needs this input and then it looks
further to see if it can generate this
input with a different rule and then it
finds this rule this gender has this as
an output and then in this case this
would be my input swamp which is already
present so this would kind of define the
define the entire dag and what it looks
like when you want to execute something
is that these rules are essentially used
to build a dag of tasks and this is just
a dependency graph for a simple dag
which only does the alignments in some
QC and errors in this case indicated
dependency from this job on the on the
previous job and tasks are executed as
soon as the preceding tasks completed so
in this case this merge job would task
would be executed as soon as this this
one succeeds and resource in that case
are taken into account for example if if
a job needs a lot of threads and they
aren't available way to execute with
executing their job and what's also very
useful that kind of run these jobs in
parallel locally can also use a cluster
if you have a cluster environment or it
can also run in coop needs clouds with
vibrance for example which I haven't
tried but I think is very useful and
it's the previous graph just showing
some dependencies but this is
essentially then for what the entire dag
would look like for a for sample
sequence over to sequencing lanes so you
see that it explodes very quickly in
terms of the number of jobs that you
have and well the analysis I typically
use this for is more in the order of
hundreds of samples so it gets big very
quickly which also indicates why I need
software to orchestrate these kind of
things and the output then of this tag
that I showed very briefly is that it
would generate alignments and at these
you can then use in further process is
to generate like these mutations and
expression counts which can then be used
in in downstream models which none we'll
talk about in there in the remainder of
this talk all right thank you very much
so what this gives us is basically to
feature matrices with samples on the
rows and features on the columns one for
DNA and one for RNA and as Julian has
alluded to we want to relate those to
treatment response or drugs
button so on the same set of tumors we
also have some form of truck response
typically have a continuous measure
namely the concentration R which the
tumor starts to respond now to relate
this to each other we can use what we
can take the drug response and the
construction we will do this by phrasing
that is regression problem where X will
be defined as the concatenation of those
DNA and RNA data into one big feature
matrix are drug responses or Y vector
and will relate that to each other by a
linear regression so fitting a vector of
badass to met X to Y we've also tried
other nonlinear methods but those don't
really add any predictive performance
over the linear case so we're gonna
stick to the simplest model here as you
probably know we obtained our baddest by
optimizing this function from here I
want to focus on a couple of very
specific disadvantages or challenges
really that we have in this kind of data
number one for example is that we
typically have way more features than we
have samples in these guises so for for
the data that I've shown here of that
I'm gonna show here we have way over
20,000 features versus only about a
thousand samples so we we're working
with a very high dimensional data and
one way to deal with that is by using
regularization so for example using
Ridge regression which means that we we
add a term to our optimization problems
to sort of prevent these batters
becoming of becoming very very large
which typically doesn't generalize very
well to other settings using rich
regression
another challenge that's specific to
this data is that we would like to make
interpretable models and on a linear
model with 20,000 regression
coefficients is now very interpretable
because we still don't really know which
genes are related to or responsible for
the truck response and that that and
ball we actually want to get biological
insights from this data because also
when we sort of biologically the model
makes sense to us we might also trust
this predictive performance more the way
we're gonna do that is or that we did
that is by using feature selection and
as it turns out when you have these sort
of penalized regression models there's a
penalty that sort of at the same
time performs feature selection as you
optimize the regression model that's
done by adding this l1 penalty as it's
called so summing over the regression
coefficients or the absolute value
actually this is when you combine these
penalties they're called elastic natural
question I'm not going to explain
exactly why this works like words but I
give an example what it looks like if we
have our feature matrix again x and y
and we have repatha coefficient then
most of our regression coefficients when
we optimize this formula will be 0 so
they won't be selected there will be
sort of like shrunk to 0 but a small
number of regression coefficients will
be nonzero there will actually be used
in the prediction and those are then
your selected features so up until a
couple of years ago this was what many
people use to predict the drug response
from DNA and RNA data when we apply
these models to this particular kind of
data we found that it was another sort
of challenge which is that there's
strong correlations between these data
types DNA and RNA are very correlated to
each other and simply concatenate in all
of the data into one big matrix action
performing your machine learning might
not be very optimal I'll give you an
example of that before I do that a bit
we'll use a slightly different data set
with a few more data types namely this
data set where we have mutation seen
against type methylation and gene
expression data types what those are
exactly is not super important for the
rest of the story but if you're
interested the first two are sort of
related to your DNA measurements and the
last one is related to your RNA
measurements now if we train this
complete model and we get a regression
coefficients bad and we're going to do
this for a lot of different trucks so we
have about 265 trucks and it's also 265
models we can visualize those models as
follows in this plot may be same five
data types and the x-axis and something
called a relative contribution of each
data type in the y-axis that's based on
our bad toss or regression coefficients
each point in this box plot corresponds
to one of those models one of those 265
trucks and what we can see here is that
almost for more than half of the model
or most of the models are almost
completely based on gene expression the
median contribution of gene expression
is a hundred percent and this is a bit
weird it could mean that maybe these are
the data types are not predictive of
drug response at all but that's actually
not what we see because when we plot
these five data types again versus to
predict the performance of an individual
data type we see that while gene
expression is the most predictive these
other data types are actually also kind
of predictive so this got us thinking
like what could be going on and before
I'm gonna hypothesize over about that as
he actually have one more slide here
which is when we came back about that
combined model that we had and we looked
at the critical at the predictive
performance of that model surprisingly
enough we see that as actually as
virtually the same predictive
performance as our gene expression based
model so the reason that we think this
is going on is as follows remember that
these data types are correlated to each
other or they're related to each other
and what we sort of know from but also
prior biological knowledge is that some
of these data types mutation seen as
cancer methylation I'll call them the
upstream they're attached from hereon
influence the gene expression through
its that may influence the Drakh
response so in other words that we think
that the upstream feeds is affected drug
response through this gene expression
and that of course means that the gene
expression is more correlated to the
drug response which then it makes sense
that a feature selection algorithm would
also select most of these gene
expression features but it's also true
that we're very much interested in these
upstream features because those are
often causally related to the drug
response and it's very they're more
interpretable in that sense if we select
those so can we somehow sort of like
prioritize the selection of these
upstream features the way that we're
going to do that is very simple remember
that a previous model combined all these
data types I'll put them in them into
one big feature matrix and then present
predicting the drug response what we're
gonna do is a two-stage approach that we
called tandem
where we first take the upstream data
types explain as much as possible of the
drug response using those data and then
in the second stage we're going to
explain the remainder using gene
expression so we're predicting the
residuals in the second stage
and to show you that it works on the
left we have to plot that we've seen a
few slides ago where we show that this
classic approach that people have been
using selects almost exclusively gene
expression features whereas in our
approach we select this is reduced by
about 50% with the remaining 50%
attributed to the other data types or
way more selection of upstream features
of course we need to check that this is
not that the expense of predictive
performance and indeed it isn't because
we pull up the predictive performers
using the classic approach first to
predict the performance using tandem
again each point is a drop here we see
that this is highly highly correlated
and there's no fear there's virtually no
identifiable shift here so just to show
you what is increased interpretability
means I give you an example so Julien
has shown you some of these networks and
this is one how this gene supposedly
worked together this is one of the drug
targets this is sort of like inhibited
by the drug all the green stuff is
selected or the light green stuff is
selected but both the classic approach
and by tandem about our approach then
the most of selected two additional ones
the dark green ones and when we started
to think about those those biologically
make a lot of sense to us with that I've
hope that I've shown you a nice overview
of how we used our bioinformatics and
machine learning to go from cells to
drug responses before I end I would like
to show you some of the what we think
are future directions in this field
sample sizes are ever-increasing and
this is mostly because the cost of
sequencing really decreases rapidly if
you look at this graph here you can see
the price on the y axis of a sequencing
a human genome versus time no does this
is actually a lock skill the prize is on
the lock skills so this some people have
suggested that the price goes down
faster than Moore's Law which sort of
suggests that were in at some point
we're not even gonna be able to keep up
computationally wise with the wanted
data that we're producing here from
sequencing this is also led to lots of
public datasets ICGC TCGA together those
contain more than 10,000 tumors right
now and more probably to come in this
kind of
jects not a cool sort of development is
the introduction of nanopore sequencing
remember this big machine that Julian
has shown on his previous slides now
there are working on very small machines
that you can plug into your laptop and
you can actually start sequencing
sequences small sequences at home these
things start at about $1,000 so those
are pretty cool so we might be seeing
more and more of those sequence data
around in terms of challenges not all is
solved tumors are very heterogeneous at
the geneious they start a single sort of
clones with one or a couple of mutations
but then they mutate into another clone
and a different clone and your treatment
might kill one clone but not the other
so tumors often become resistant to the
treatments that we're giving them so
ideally were sequencing it and we should
be sequencing at multiple places in
patients or over time to see what how
does the other tumors evolve and what
kind of different clones do we have and
so how does that affect treatment and of
course these sort of different samples
per patient also affect our statistical
models and how we should think about
those and finally here we've shown you
sort of like an approach that takes all
of the genes together and simply uses
regression to predict the Drakh response
another approach would be to sort of
incorporate prior knowledge and sort of
a bottom-up start starting with these
networks and slowly adding genes that we
think are relevant and this is often
done by computational often Bayesian
modeling of gene networks within tumor
cells those were our perspectives on the
future and thank you very much I'd like
to wrap up and we're happy to take
questions
[Applause]
so the question is whether the
treatments response is a binary variable
in this case we're looking at response
to the drug where we were where the
response is indicated there's a
continuous variable namely the
concentration at which the tumor started
responding and maybe as a slight like
addition to what I've told you here is
that the data set have shown you here is
actually something of about tumors that
are kept in the lab so they're outside
of a patient and they grow in a dish in
the lab actually so that's why we can
test different concentrations and
actually see which concentrates to start
did the tumor start to response they
absolutely derived and in typical
clinical situations if you've got data
from a clinical trial from patients that
have been treated you usually look at
either binary response rate or or some
ordinal response rate of response
partial response or no response
so the question is their large part of
the DNA that are not relevant and how do
we identify those so we're focusing on
on the parts that are genes so that's
already just about 3% of the entire
genome and of that 3% those genes most
are in some way typically relevant not
to every drug but that's why we're doing
the feature selection so those are the
multiple ways to correlate these things
you can either look at genes that are
often mutated in certain cancer types
which is more like just looking at
mutation frequencies and also people
often use like prior knowledge in this
case as well will they know that a
certain gene is plays an important role
in certain processes but also just
relating to your remark about that a lot
of the genomes and isn't important
that's not entirely true
so like the remark that DNA consists of
only genes is very simplifying it's a
bit of a simplification because there's
also a lot of research going into all
kind of sequences that are not coding
for genes but do have a lot of into do
you have a lot of effect on gene
expression via all kind of feedback and
regulation mechanisms so this is more or
less some of the simpler stuff and there
is a lot of biology on biology on the
walls there's a lot more difficult to
understand but also one of the issues is
if you find mutations in a gene which
you have no idea what the gene is doing
then it's not very easy to do anything
actionable with because you have no idea
what kind of drug you should develop to
target this or what the gene is actually
doing biologically to the tumor
so the question is whether age or weight
or things like that matter to the
response in these clinical studies so
not the ones that we're doing with the
cells in the lab but in clinical studies
those are different typical parameters
have taken into account and age is very
predictive of whether someone's gonna
make it for another ten years say
because if someone is already very old
they might die sooner or more likely I
work with that's data from the lab which
is why my phrasing was not very nice
just now I guess
well the genes do have a the rate the
question was why do you focus on genes
and if those other things like weight
etc there's definitely lots of research
there too but the reason to focus on the
genes is that typically tumors
originated by genetic defects so the
rationale is to also target those
defects using drugs and that the
information of which drugs will work
where where it's sort of like related to
those genetic defects so that's why
we're looking at the genetic data there
I think a lot of clinical variables like
weight age have a strong influence on
what kind of gem you develop like breast
cancer is typically in older women for
example after menopause but not
necessarily like Nana said how much in
response or how how it originates and
how responsive treatment is more defined
by the genetic features and that's why
after well you could you can you could
determine for a long time how old
someone was and try to correlate that
with a treatment response but like doing
this sort of genetic approach is much
newer and this adds to that approach
basically and I think you can explain
much more from the genetic side of
things and from there from just looking
at clinical variables
saying so one very big difference with
sorry how does snake back to so the
question was how does a snake make
relates you for example other workflow
tools like air flow and so one big
difference I think is that snake make is
more like local new make for those of
you who remember new make and in that
sense it focuses a lot of files and it
focused a lot of like it starts with
what you want your results and then
trace it back to what you through the
rules that it has to its inputs and it's
very much file oriented compared to air
flow where air flow is much more time
oriented where you schedule jobs to run
at specific time intervals and this is
more like I get a data set with a
certain set of samples and I want to
generate predefined set of outputs from
from these samples that I get so in that
sense it's yeah very different I think
so the question is whether because of
the high dimensionality problem we
shouldn't or we should we could try to
use principle component analysis to
reduce the dimensionality and go from
there
people have done that it works well it
doesn't necessarily work better than the
approach we discussed here the predicted
performance is roughly the same and the
the major advantage of doing doing
feature selection immediately is that
it's the interpretability because you're
really looking at a small set of genes
that are related to your drug response
rather than a linear combination of once
again actually all of the genes
the question was what do you do when you
don't have a dose at which the tumor
responds or react and how do you handle
that case because you have to do some
sort of extrapolation well that's
actually answer we do some sort of
extrapolation we realize that there is
some inherent noise to that because
while you're extrapolating and it's not
necessarily easy still we've tried some
other approaches like just binarize yet
but there is a difference between
responding a little and responding a lot
so we we do sort of prefer to use the
concentration in the end and still these
explanations they all tend to accelerate
their response in the resistant part at
least there is there are some things
that you can do that we didn't really
discuss that are probably well-suited
for offline discussion because they're
going to curve fitting really
[Applause]